hello everyone this game is one of many
in Fishers path to conquer to chest
Olympus it was played in 1971 but two
weeks before this game was played
Fischer actually plays his quarterfinal
match against mark taimanov and Fischer
annihilated time mental with a result of
6 to 0 and the timeline of some years
later even wrote a book called how I
became Fischer's the victim but this is
a game from the match casual Larsen this
is the first game of the match and it is
it's my favorite game of this match so
let's hit this game Bobby Fischer is
white and bent Larsen is black so we
have e 4 e 6 d 4 D 5 the print the 10th
Knight to c3 Bishop to b4 b5 9 3 7 a3
Bishop captures on c3 be captures on c3
and c5 and here Fischer goes for a very
interesting line a 4 we have Knight B to
c6 Knight to f3 Bishop to d7 to Bishop
to b3 Queen to c7 and Fischer castles
and we have C for a large someone's to
kick this Bishop out of this strong
diagonal so with a Bishop to e2 and now
f6 Larsson is trying to break Fischer
strong point central chain so Fisher
plays the rook to e1 and now nice to g6
threatening that II d5 pawn and here
Fischer sacrifices this pawn and place
the bishop to a3 Fisher doesn't want to
allow Larson to Castle kingside and well
he shouldn't really care for Queen side
since this line is open for the rook so
we have Tess captures on e5 d captures
on e5 Knight see captures on d5 Knight
captures on d5 and knife captures on d5
and here fish replace a queen to d4 just
a very strong centralizing move well
attacking the knight also threatening
some ideas like Bishop to h5 check so
Larson plays Knight back to g6 and the
Fischer pins it
Bishop to h5 so we have King to f7 by
Larson and now f4
a very active move by Fischer we have
rook h3 8 and Fischer pushes f5 and now
well this point has to be captured since
black will lose the night so we have D
captures on f5 and Queen captures on d5
would check Larson place came to
six and we have Bishop to f3 kind of
going for this B seven points so Larson
place a nice to e5 and well if Fisher
with Catherine b7 now Elle Larson would
capture the bishop with the night and
after the Queen recaptures let's play
Bishop to c6 and this would be OK for
black so instead they replace back Queen
back to d4 against to the nice
centralizing square and pinning the
night so we have King to g6 unpinning
and now Fischer plays a very nice move
he plays row casters on e5 simply
removing the defender of this Bishop on
d7 and well the rook can't really
capture since Fisher would play Bishop
to d6 and this would lose a rope so
after roof to e5 time ago I mean Larsen
played Queen captures and if I haven't
facial capture the bishop and d7 and we
have erupted a to d8 by Larson and well
Oh
Fisher does have two bishops for a rope
but Larsen's rooks are extremely active
and the Fisher does have to play this
very precisely so if you replace going
to be seven capturing that pawn we have
a queen tv3 check King to f1 and not
Kings to h1 this will allow Queen to e1
we have R up to d2 and this is a very I
mean this is the critical position of
the game and it's it's beautiful how
Fischer handles it because Larsson is
threatening checkmate on f2 so Fischer
starts with Queen to c6 check Larson
defends this with RIPTA e6 also now
attacking white Fischer's queen and now
Fischer plays Bishop to c5 attacking
Larsen's Queen this allows Larson a
tactic which you plays but you'll see
how it turns out
Larsson place a rook to f2 check Fisher
place King to g1 and now rook captures
on g2 with a double check from the rook
and the Queen so Fisher has the capture
King captures in g2 and now Queen to d2
and with this Queen to d2 check a
Fischer has to move his King and now
well Fischer isn't attacking Larsen's
Queen and
so we have King th1 and now Larson wins
the Queen rook captures on c6 and Bishop
captures on c6 and this is a very
interesting position a lot of people
have put this position up to some very
strong engines and those very strong
engines actually say that black can play
this to a draw but I don't know I mean
if you're Larson in this position you
know that you're playing Bobby Fischer
who just annihilated mark Timon over the
result of six to zero and the Fisher
just sacrificed his Queen and is on the
verge of winning the brilliancy in in
the first game of the match and the
clock is ticking so I don't really think
that anything an engine has to say in
this position is is in any way relevant
solar someplace Queen captures on c3
attacking that broken a1 and a fish
removes the would attempt or up the g1
check so we have King to f6 and now
Fischer captures an a7 and the Fischer
has created a very strong platform here
this a for pawn so we have a g5 by
Larsson Bishop to b6 preparing to push
the point Queen casters on c2 and now
Larson has also created a very strong
passed pawn here so we have a five by
Fischer Queen to be - by Larson fish
replace Bishop TDH check King to e6 and
now pushes a six and we have Queen to a3
attacking the pawn bishop to b7
protecting the pawn and now Queen to c5
protecting that a7 square and face
replace a rock to be one preparing
Bishop to b6 and this is well
undefendable Larsson price c3 and
bishops plays Bishop to b6 and in this
position Larson resigned it's impossible
to play something like C 2 because rook
to e1 check wins immediately and I will
just show a line what would happen if
Larson decided to continue playing this
for example C - like I said C two losses
immediately but for example Queen to e5
you'd have a 7c to rub the g1 Quinta c3
preparing to push
white would get a queen and after c1
Queen rook captures on c1 Queen captures
on c1 you get Bishop did you want and
well like us without the move figures up
to bishops and this is completely
winning so yeah an incredible starts to
this match by Fisher and I will let you
know that the Fisher actually won this
match with a result of 6 to 0 as well
and he continued to the finals of the
candidate to face Tigran Petrosian and
well one could say that he also crushed
England patrolling the result was six
and a half to two and a half and well
Fischer only lost one game it was the
second game in the match against
Petrosyan and then he threw three games
and won four games in a row so if you
think about a favor actually played
three of the strongest players in the
world and he annihilated two of them
with a result of six to zero and then he
crushed a former world champion Tigran
Petrosian with a result of six and a
half to two and a half so something like
that's happening today I mean I don't
see it I I don't see I don't think this
could happen today I mean no one is this
strong today so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and well yeah I
do hope you know that after Fisher
defeated
Petrosyan he was the rightful challenger
to the crown and was ready to challenge
Spassky in their reykjavik match in 1972
so yeah that's it I would like to thank
everyone who contributed to my channel
in any way whatsoever and as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon